so I want to know an update on your uh
dating life what do you mean
Well you're dating yeah well not only
that can I just tell you guys what that
what dating looks like for about all
right well that's not called no names no
names no names okay all right Marissa
hargate I have never seen someone go at
such lightning speed on three
simultaneous dating apps and I mean he's
swiping life well he's swiping life he
kind of is swiping live He's swiping
he's swiping left on the hottest chicks
like I look at it I'm like I cannot
believe okay nice you're impossible to
impress he has standards
you think I just look at the photo of
the person
I look at background what where are they
standing what is that is is that a is
that a chicken finger chicken finger on
her bed I think you said chicken is that
a Ching finger on her bed got nervous
there for a second yeah yeah that's what
I meant to say oh okay and I just go
that's racist
I don't want two fingers on anybody's
bed right protecting yes dude no I look
at like if they're doing something like
they could be beautiful but if they're
doing something that I don't want to be
doing yeah like skydiving or like
playing golf or like going to a club I
just immediately I don't want anything
to do with it right so I look at clothes
that sometimes I'll see the first photo
I'm not sure so I'll go the second the
second photo I'll make a decision
they're mostly laughs for 13 hours of
that entire flight from LA to Manila it
was just hinge hinge hinge I could not
believe my eyes lightning but can I say
this no Bumble out of them
why am I bumble three of them
simultaneously so he's on Raya bum
before Tinder and hinge all of them yeah
tinders yeah Tinder Tinder it's
mythological it's interesting it's if um
if if Middle Earth had like a dating app
that's what Tinder is because I've
literally seen goblins
I don't want to be rude
I saw a cave troll you know what I mean
I have
you know at a club you know what I mean
do you not think that maybe she thinks
the same of you when she comes across
exactly I look like [ __ ] you know I
mean yellow Golem two trolls won't make
a right she's like ah yellow yeah they
make a laugh they make a laugh they make
it they make a huge trolls don't make a
right they make a left write that down I
have a question for you yeah could we
we're here in the Philippines for a week
could we maybe set you up on like three
dates maybe I like this idea one of you
guys can help us JJ
well JJ and I have something else okay
we got that part right all right so we
have no it it's so crazy because it's
not even what you think it is
not busy it's not about Lucy what are
you guys doing
he's a Mormon
a Phillip oh yeah yeah and we're gonna
go to the temple Thursday yeah and we're
gonna go I'm gonna get baptized
it's a Mormon yeah the Mormons okay
right didn't you say the temple yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then we're
gonna go to that new uh that new um
dumpling place that on Sunday we're
gonna be in mott oh okay way to go there
mod okay yeah and then
um
they want to get some [ __ ]
okay no we're not gonna do anything like
that but my point is the date today so
what what is your criteria what is like
the top five things that is most that
are most important to you when you're
looking at a girl on any of these sites
I'll be honest with you and this is the
truth I'm I'm talking sexual right now
and all this stuff but there is somebody
that
a couple of people I've met
that I like that I'm kind of seeing so
that being said
that's the truth
I like that I like hang out with and
that I like their energy and um maybe
you know I have a curious question uh do
you ever when you're swiping in the back
your mind do you ever
put kalila in like like you're comparing
ever yeah she's here's that's the [ __ ]
up part
shut up that's the truth or just the
truth we're being truthful little
coochie mama
now
anyway yeah it's obviously you know
there's a level right and it's not just
about looks it's about you know
you know what me and kalila had what her
interests you know we have the same
interests we have the same we like the
same kind of music and movies and tastes
right so all those things you know come
into play it's a terrible thing to have
but um but also I because you had asked
me
um the other day you were like what do
you talk you know what do you talk about
when like you're dating somebody and
sometimes you get worried that you know
that the person that you're seeing like
their sensibilities don't match yours
but I think that's a good thing like
that you you they don't need to like all
the same movies you like they don't need
to like you don't have to share the same
hobbies and I think that you're missing
the point of actually getting to know
someone like you can still be fully
invested in someone and not share the
same like Hobbies or likes or any of
that yeah I'm not skydiving well not
skydiving that's like once every five
years I'm just saying I'm not doing that
or golf but I'm not doing any of that
Hey listen you're right there are
sometimes some a girl will go well have
you seen this movie you've done this
or whatever some of the movies of course
one girl yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
the other guy the the um with the dogs
in the Mexicans
I learned all that [ __ ] from you and I
was I didn't know about that [ __ ] and I
was open to that stuff and I watched and
I go that's a part of my like film
repertoire in my mind right so yeah I am
open to that but if they're like I've
only seen Ghostbusters too
or whatever yeah I cannot date them
there's because they have no
lust for film
I have a lust for movies I watch garbage
bad movies foreign films Criterion
Collection I watch it all okay so the
horror whatever you know would you say
that's part of
um your top five
um requests or criteria movies you've
got to have some taste in movies video
games
okay so so they have to have some sort
of video game addiction okay oh
addiction not addiction but you know
yeah I play you know
something something like this okay
second so some kind of video game gamer
even Oculus if they're oculusing someone
just really into Oculus they're Oculus
thing around the house that'd be cool
you know what I mean and then number two
you know some interest in movies and
television
and comedy or whatever it's the same
interest that I have
um and then number three they can't play
golf
wait at all
I hate golf what if they hey what if
they're hardcore Gamers is it because
you're
down he's competing with the golf club
we should play to do some we should play
though I'm not playing golf with you
dude to break it to really have you
break the white break the [ __ ] club
on my body like my dad to break through
break through what